on
dans le cadre du développement du
plateau de paris saclay on assiste à
l'arrivée de nombreuses entreprises
écoles et avec elle un besoin croissant
de logements pour des étudiants et des
apprentis résidences sociales de france
qui est une filiale du groupe 3f s'est
associé avec arpège une association qui
gère des résidences étudiantes et on a
répondu à un appel à candidature on a
été sélectionné et on a donc développé
ce projet avec deux agences
d'architecturé une agence belge 51 une
4e et une agence nantaise pour vous et
grains d'orge et l'idée du projet est de
le ps c'était qu'on se dise que les
logements étudiants on ne les habite pas
comme des logements classiques mais on
vit au sein d'un campus avec tout ce que
cela comprend d'interaction le projet
architectural de l'opération il comprend
trois bâtiments on a deux petits
bâtiment de deux niveaux qui sont
construits en béton préfabriqué de
couleur rouge assez intense et le plus
grand des bâtiments qui à la fois le
plus grand par sa longueur et par sa
hauteur reprend cette idée de socle
rouge en béton préfabriqué sur lequel
viennent se poser cinq niveaux de
logements en béton rose clair
on a trois entités principales dans
l'opération une partie logement étudiant
qui accueillera 330 étudiants ou
apprentis
on a proposé des espaces communs
qualitatif qui permettent d'être des
vrais lieux de rencontre le hall qui est
de taille
agréable les salles polyvalentes des
salles d'études et des laverie
collective
la deuxième entité cd restaurant puisque
au sein même du bâtiment on aura deux
restaurants un restaurant universitaire
et un restaurant interentreprises
respectivement 2000 et 800 couverts et
enfin des locaux commerciaux dont la
nature reste à définir
en tout on construit plus de onze mille
mètres carrés
les spécificités de cette opération
c'est d'une part qu on propose des
colocations puisque c'est une formule à
laquelle on croit en logements étudiants
donc outre des classiques studio qu'on
peut trouver habituellement on propose
des logements pour deux ou quatre
étudiants qui partagent une cuisine et
un séjour et l'autre spécificité c'est
justement d'avoir pensé les espaces
communs et les espaces de circulation
comme de véritables espaces de rencontre
et de convivialité
le projet doit être livré pour la
rentrée universitaire 2016 avec des
étudiants qui rentreront à partir de
septembre ce qui nous laisse sept petits
mois de chantier pour l'instant on est
dans les temps